ladies and gentlemen it's true jay
mazzini
has been arrested wow
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla and today
while we have a coffeezilla first listen
a lot of times we talk about fake gurus
nothing happens in this case he
was arrested and not for the reason you
think
because it wasn't for the bitcoin it
wasn't for
the uh clothing scam it wasn't for any
of the scams
that we've covered on this channel and
in fact
i'm still uh asking for information if
you've been scammed in the bitcoin scam
and you are in the new york
city area dm me in the next 24 hours and
i know it looks like i haven't slept
but uh that's mostly the lighting you
know everyone keeps saying like steven
you got to get some rest dude it's the i
don't know how to light myself oh that's
a little better a little better a little
better okay
my point is is that i'm fine thank you
for your concern though
thank you uh but i'm i'm totally fine
what i care about is seeing the victims
get the justice they deserve
and seeing this guy it brought to
justice as well
so all of this is good news but let's go
over
what he was charged with because you
guys will find it fascinating but again
i can't say this enough if you're from
new york i've been posting it everywhere
the new york city area and you were
approached by jay mazzini
for the bitcoin scam get in touch get in
touch
with sifu coffeezilla okay please
okay so let's go over this shall we this
just got made public and again i have to
be really careful with what i say here
because i know a lot that's not public i
also know a lot that is public
so i'm gonna be really treading lightly
but what i will tell you is that when
all of this is
over i will be sharing the full
information with you guys okay so don't
worry about it
we will be talking about the whole thing
can't talk about it yet
but we we will be sharing the entire
thing so you can see right here
there's the alias information jay
mazzini
jabara j igbara he's an inmate
over at fort lee and no bond
has been posted and i don't know if
they're even allowing him bond
uh but let's go over the charges shall
we because
these are unbelievable okay so let's do
this let's let's go over here real quick
it might be easier
okay so here's the main charge
kidnapping jay mazzini was arrested
for kidnapping aggravated assault
luring or enticing of an adult so he
kidnapped an adult is what we we know
publicly uh possession of a weapon for
unlawful purpose
criminal coercion threat to inflict
bodily injury endangering of an injured
victim
and terroristic threats threat of crime
or of violence ladies and gentlemen
that is what jay mazzini is currently in
jail for and these are the charges
that he is facing again these are all
alleged
but this is what we know
now could any of us have seen this
coming
well to be honest i'm not too surprised
okay i've been saying
since i've kind of figured out what this
guy's mo is i've just been kind of like
it's only a matter of time till we hear
that i mean we knew it but
boy oh boy was i surprised to see this i
mean kidnapping i thought he was just a
scammer
and you know we don't know the full
details publicly yet
but um more
more on that hopefully coming don't
worry
we're gonna get into all i'm so excited
you guys should see into my head right
now
this is a huge dub for the
scam i'm so happy that um
you guys owe yourselves a round of
applause listen
people have been taking your money for
so long and finally these guys are going
they're getting brought to justice and i
i for one
couldn't be happier about it but wow
this is quite intense i um
again if you're from the new york area
and you have information about the
bitcoin scam
you were scammed by bitcoin you know
someone who was please get in touch with
me
but yeah that's basically it that's all
i can share
right now the story is epic
i almost want to make it into a netflix
doc i mean it is
so insane the details of this are so
unbelievable that yesterday i was just
like pacing my house i was like
oh my gosh this is this is netflix this
is like
anyway i don't wanna it's too much it's
too much dude i know i'm just debating
you guys but
um again kidnapping
possession of weapon for unlawful
purpose aggravated assault
i mean these are big charges ladies and
gentlemen
and um
it's unbelievable okay so i don't have
too much more i can share with you right
now
just know the j mazzini story is not
over
and if you have information happy to
take uh
twitter instagram gmail um
otherwise if you're not from new york
city and you're not involved in the
bitcoin scam
don't forget pump the stock ladies and
gentlemen pump it up
zilla okay people were telling me
yesterday there's actually a penny stock
called zilla
clearly that's not what i'm talking
about i'm talking about the youtuber
stock
zilla coffeezilla be sure to pump the
ticker and
uh thanks for watching keep an eye out
see you in the next one
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream